so full transparency this is a sponsored
video but at San Diego comic-con this
year
Leko invited me out to take over their
Instagram providing trivia and quick
facts to their fans which was incredibly
exciting for those of you guys who had a
chance to see it for those of you who
weren't able to make it out to San Diego
Legos booth was crazy amazing they had a
boatload of like exclusive models and
they had these life model Lego Batman
Lego SIF trooper and Lego Iron Man
builds and everyone who went was able to
create their own comic I loved it
actually named it after you guys The
Adventures of the robbed Corps but I was
also given a handful of collectibles and
sets to bring back and unbox for
everybody on my channel so for the Lego
collectibles these were exclusive to San
Diego comic-con and consisted of Lego
Batman Lego barber from stranger things
and lego spider-man now starting with
lego Barbara I was particularly fond of
this item since Barbara was one of my
favorite characters from the series
since she was the person who served as
our eyes and ears throughout her time in
the first season
now the Lego Batman collectible is
modeled after the version of his
character from Detective Comics 275
where he encountered a villain named
zebra man possessing super-strength and
the power of magnetism zebra man used an
inhibitor belt to control his powers
which were given to him by science
basically but when Batman was hit with
the same machinery and given the same
powers along with a zebra costume he was
unable to control any of these abilities
and ended up pushing everyone and
everything away like Bruce Wayne
normally does in the comics now
eventually he reverses polarity caught
up with zebra man and then handed him
over to the cops but it's a cool
throwback to one of Batman's more
interesting stories now for a lego
spider-man this is modeled after the ps4
version of his character and is signed
by Yuri Lowenthal who voiced Peter in
the game now one of the things I always
enjoyed about the ps4 version of
spider-man and this Lego spider-man
minifigure was the costume design while
the older design is a classic and up
until that point
superior spider-man was probably my
favorite design this one actually took
over that because there's something just
invigorating about seeing a new version
of the costume and judging by the fan
reception to it I was the only one who
loved it now for the Lego sets these
were pretty straightforward much like
the collectibles these were exclusive to
San Diego comic-con
and each box came with a set of building
instructions and the Lego bricks were
individually packaged now building time
was relatively short given the size of
the sets and range from Lego Batman to
Lego Captain Marvel and a Lego sift
ruber now truth to tell the Lego sister
set took the longest to build but when
they were all said and done
each set came out exactly the way that
I'd hoped now i've recently begun
remodeling my office and i've been
looking for some items that would
provide a good blend between a clean
aesthetic look and geek culture and so
combining these with other items gave me
exactly what I was looking for now the
only real suggestion I would make with
regards to these sets particularly Lego
Batman Lego Captain Marvel and other
superheroes that exists throughout Legos
offerings would be to provide maybe a
little booklet or a pamphlet that kind
of gives you these fast facts sort of
gives you a stripped-down origin or a
set of their powers or something along
those lines but something that can help
towards expanding somebody's knowledge
of whatever the item is that they're
going through instead of just somebody
building it I mean it is a fun
experience I really enjoyed it enough
for me it was actually really relaxing
in order to sit down and just let these
things build to just turn everything off
the TV the radio the whole nine yards
just sit in silence and build these sets
I really enjoyed it but I think it would
go a long way towards educating those
who are buying these sets with regards
to the characters and in their
backgrounds or what have you but again
just kind of a suggestion of sorts but
with that being said guys we're gonna go
and bring this video to an end I want to
go ahead and throw this out there let
you guys know this was there it was
really really enjoyable I loved being at
the Lego booth it was an absolute blast
first time I've ever been to San Diego
it was really really amazing but without
me said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end that will catch you all
later purse
[Music]